[Music]
what do you remember about this at the
time i was just working with this bloke
john
now i look back and i was working with
john lennon
we were writing songs that were
memorable because we had to remember
them
how did this happen it was a question of
me john or george becoming the bass
player
the two of them said well i'm not doing
it
when could you look back and realize
what we did back then was
really special i clearly remember when
ringo kicked in
it was like wow he's really good
[Music]
a good little song
i brought in the chords and then george
mann said it'd be nice if we could have
a little intro
and harrison just went
yeah he was good you know
[Music]
what you got now this one
this is why we don't go into tapes it's
beautiful
[Music]
number one in the usa that was a party
night that's where the audience applauds
you wait for it wait for it
i'm amazed clearly yeah these guys are
going for it
we were warned don't go out late and the
car pulls up
some guys jumped out one of them had a
knife and they took all our demos
we were hippies we just did not listen
[Applause]
i want to read to you one thing paul is
one of the most innovative bass players
that ever played bass
and the stuff that's going on now is
ripped off from his beetle period he's a
great
great musician did i write that that is
john lennon that's john
yeah i hadn't heard that that's
beautiful
you